[Music]
thank you
hey guys
um
so I bought a ND filter for the camera
hopefully you can you're going to be
able to see the screen better what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna do like a very
very very basic kind of how to start
programming mass at all
okay
um if you press over here
so usually after you start up the
machine especially on a smooth your
Matrix
it's gonna look a little bit differently
obviously
and uh
so this is how you start uh smooth
there's a power button
right on the bottom over here
and let's say You're Gonna you wanna
make a program
and we're gonna do it I'm gonna try to
simplify it as much as possible you go
to the position button
is going to take you to the main main
page
whatever whatever program the machine is
going to be reading at the current time
that's going to be over here as you're
gonna see work number this page is what
the machine is going to be running
this page is whatever program you're on
so that means you can run a program one
or you can create a program too and you
can start programming one once the
program one is still running
but you cannot edit program one while
the mission is running so they give you
ability to make a new program make
changes but not
in time when the machine is running if
it makes sense because you obviously
cannot make a change to your program
because you know that could cause a
cause a problem but
um without being technical
make sure that this
number matches this number
and I'm going to talk about this in a
second so we're gonna create a a new
program
okay
um so actually pick a left soft key
okay it's gonna take you to the page
over here pick the third one from the
left program
okay and it will give you whatever
program you're on right now let's do
work number
it's gonna populate a work number
selection
and if it's not something you have in
directory if it's a new program you want
to make
just press this one let's create a
program number one to keep it simple
I'll press one
enter
and if it's not in the directory it's
going to take you to a blank blank page
your program number is going to be up in
the left corner
okay and you have three options work
number ISO programming that's going to
be your g code in the master troll
program
let's pick mazatrol
okay
so now you're gonna have a top bar
okay and on the top bar it's gonna show
you a different selection all these
like cast iron back you know uh big
stainless aluminums and all these things
they usually come with some pre-loaded
uh parameters for a depth of cut a feed
speeds
um you can call them suggestions
um you can also make adjustments these
within parameters I usually go with
stainless steel because like I said I I
set my own parameter
yeah
see I'm trying to move
I'm gonna pin it so it doesn't keep
floating
now it's going to ask me first question
so you press it says OD Max
okay right on the bottom
it always tells you maximum outside
diameter of work piece
what this does let's say if you have two
inches part you can call it two inches
or a little bit bigger cannot be smaller
but what this is gonna do once the part
for example
you're when your turret this is a two
inch part your tour is going to come in
okay go a little bit higher and then
head home versus if you tell the machine
you need more clearance because you have
a tail start over here and you tell the
maximum part is eight inches it will go
eight inches up in the air and then go
home so for clearance I always actually
add a little bit more now for example
if you do
um a lot of Milling a lot of everything
and the Machine what it does is let's
say it goes up the part rotates and
whatnot or goes up and then it comes
back it will go up to eight inches and
then come back so it does a lot of
unnecessary travel in those situations I
keep it pretty close to what the
material is just to shorten these uh you
know travel times
additional that are not necessary but in
this uh
in this uh example we're gonna go let's
say eight inches ID like how small your
internal is going to be zero the
workpiece length
um same thing is like always give more
that what you have also
if for example if you have a bar
okay and you're doing a bunch of
sections right so you have an inch bar
you know from here to here
and you're doing sections so your
machine cut off machine cut off machine
cut off so this is going to be hard to
see with the tradition but what it does
is you have to add these together so if
you have eight inches bar and you have
eight eight slugs one inch each
uh you can't say your length is one inch
you have to add them together and you
say that it's eight inches even add more
juice for safety but let's call it eight
inches
then you work face your work face
okay
your work face over here that's going to
be how much stock do you remove from
face so let's say you have a two three
hundred thousand stock and whatnot the
machine will come at 300 000 before it
will get to your zero on facing
undrolling on everything so you so I
always add a little bit extra just in
case to give me like additional uh space
or clearance if let's say you make a
mistake you set your zero you know not
like you make you made a mistake at
least you have a lot of little space you
know and then it becomes 300 before the
part and it's gonna stop then it's gonna
retract back to let's say forty thousand
and then it's gonna start cutting so
work phase let's call it 200 and this
last one is your maximum rpm so maximum
rpm and it says Max turning spindle RPM
I have a problem focusing
um
yeah I'm gonna figure out see how that
Focus works so maximum turning spindle
limit is depends how big your chalk is
if you have a 15 inch Chuck obviously
you're not going to go 2000 RPMs if
using a collet then you can go three
four thousand and my first unit that I
always go to if you watch my videos
okay you have all we have all choices I
always use the end in the beginning
continue no because this is not a let's
say production job
number it says part counter yes or no if
you're doing a few parts then you don't
care about Counting
return
position menu
you have two choices on the left two
change position or zero position we want
to go to Tool change
with the tool change position is
so like for example this jewel is my
longest uh it's my longest tool on the
machine right now
okay and it's the longest set in the two
Library so what this Mission will do
she's gonna attack this zero of the part
okay it will go up and it's gonna
retract to the longest tool plus you
know additional uh whatever default is
by the machine before it will rotate the
tool and pick another tool to come back
and continue Machining so that's all
that is so it's a safety kind of feature
and then it says next workpiece number
next workpiece number is when you jump
from one program to a second program so
for example you do first site
or you have uh or do you you might do a
same same piece but you might want to do
like different Z positions and whatnot
you can create like a sub program and
jump to another program but we don't
care for that
and uh so yeah so now we have our
program
so I remember mazatrol one
right away what I'm gonna do what I do
personally I go to the position
and this is my old setup page right
left key setup info
[Applause]
work number
then I pick the program that I just
created so I'm gonna highlight one
press ok
I make sure my number one is here
and what I do is turning spindle I go to
jaw data I do just not mount it I
usually bring the tools myself manually
to make sure I'm clearing the jaws and
then set my Z let's call it 20 000 right
now
I'm gonna press teach the teacher is
very very important
because if you're not going to press the
teach it's gonna it's it's gonna put
twenty thousand over here that machine
is telling you this is what you want to
put in now we want to teach the machine
that this is twenty thousand uh my my
part is at twenty thousand right now I'm
gonna press enter
populist number
hit the left key
position
and I want to check
C 20 000
program one all right we're all good so
we we are ready to program Now to create
a program
right now it just gives you work number
search program edits tools and layouts
and whatnot
um let's say you press here you want to
do something
you don't have any options you have to
do a program at it
now that your program added it's going
to give you all these beautiful options
okay so we're at the end right now it's
highlighted we have to insert the line
because the end always has to be at the
end so we're gonna go all the way here
press that soft key last one
okay
so by the connects to calculate between
calculate and erase we have insert I'm
gonna press the insert yes okay
now we have additional line over here
okay so first unit it's highlighted
it gives you the options on the bottom
Point light line face those are Mills
all our returning options are here we
want to turn what are we going to do we
want to face the part first right
okay so we are facing
it says finish Z
finish allowance on Z how much stock do
we wanna do uh finish we can go anywhere
between three to five thousand it
depends uh on your case
now it's asking which to It's Gonna
automatically populate some tools so
let's say we have 80 uh rougher and the
second one automatically 80 rougher but
I don't want to either rougher I do want
to use a different tool for finishing
I'm gonna press this
and then I can put 35r
or I can go all the way to the bottom
and it says tool data window
once you press that
you're gonna have a two data and it's
gonna it's going to show you only the
tools that are capable of doing the task
uh of facing or OD turning or whatever
you're programming so I have as you see
80r 35r and 55r I'm gonna pick 35 right
I'm gonna press ok
once I press the OK the 35 is here
okay and what's the depth of cut let's
call it 20 000.
okay now
it says surface speed
so it's cutting speed over here
sorry not surface but cutting speed I'm
gonna go with 320.
feed rate
eight thousand
M8
uh two 280 to 320 is usually like a safe
Zone uh feed rate for roughing 8 000 to
12 000 is also good depends on the
materials and your
on the bottom so this was rougher now
we're using a finishing
let's go 500
speed and 4 000 feet rate that's gonna
spin a little faster and the tools going
going down a little bit slower that's
going to give us a nicer finish
and let's call it an M8
okay once once you press enter
it's gonna populate our first line on
the first line is it's a starting point
x well our part is two inches I'm gonna
go start two inches and a hundred
thousand a little bit above the part
and then starting point Z well how much
stock do we have on a z let's call it
twenty thousand right we touch up the
part and we we told the machine this is
a twenty thousand uh from zero so we
have twenty thousand stock
final point x well where do we want to
go we want to go all the way to the
center so we can cut the whole part
so we're gonna press zero and then final
Point Z
and like I said like all your all your
questions are gonna be here on the
bottom
final point three we want to go all the
way down to zero so pretty much once
this uh unit is done
[Applause]
this part
where it starts is going to be right at
a zero
all right
so now let's do OD turning
okay so go over here
right key insert
press ok
so unit highlighted
go to turning
same thing let's go through all the
options
OD turning it's gonna say bar out copy
what copy is it's uh it's something
similar to OD turning
but it's um it's gonna be hard for me
but instead of like uh turning
when it goes you know let's say uh from
the face uh throughout the park this
actually copies the shape
uh then you have your Corners your
facing which we did your threading cycle
your grooving Cycles
[Music]
[Applause]
to remove the all right maybe better a
Threading cycle your grooving cycle your
drilling cycles and your capping cycle
okay these are all your options for for
turning so now we're gonna go
with the bar out and we'll see which
video is going to come up better the one
with the filter without filter
so we're gonna go bar out
and now he's gonna ask this question
cutting connects well we know our part
is two inches so let's start cutting
from two inches
a cutting Point uh Z where do we want to
start cutting from so we cutting from
zero
FNX and F and Z finish on your X and
finish your new Z let's go ten thousand
on X and 3000 on Z so once we press
enter
it starts to populate again you're
rougher and you're finished
automatically applied some tools I don't
like the 80. I can the same thing I can
put 35 R over here
or I can go here pick my data again from
all the tools that capable of doing such
tasks press ok
and now pattern
which pattern do you want this is how
you took the machine is going to retract
it's gonna cut and go up
because it retracts a little bit and
then goes up
or it goes under an angle
and this number two I actually don't
know I never tried it so so I usually go
with a zero
uh next question
okay that is highlighted
and you see let me see that one
and over here it says maxed up of a cut
let's go 80 000.
okay so all these are there's nothing
else to fill out then your cutting
speeds your your feed rate and M8 and
all these things right so cutting speed
so let's go 320.
feeds eight thousand and code M8 it does
different cooling down and now we're
gonna do the same thing for finish
[Applause]
500.004 for finish M8
and uh just to clarify so I press enter
it take me to this button
this box
I'm gonna press enter is going to take
me to this box once I press enter again
that's when it's gonna finally get
populate the line for me so as you see
see if I can do it for you okay I'm
gonna press enter next box enter boom
okay now it's next one so I made a
little drawing over here
so on this drawing so we have a two inch
part
okay and it's got a quarter it's got a
250 or quarter corner so 250 000. now
there's two ways to do it you can do a
line
okay so first choice so we have line
your tapers your outer and then the
radiuses we can do a line
and then it's going to ask you start
Corner this is that first uh do you want
a corner radius
I could say 250 000 right
press enter
and it's gonna see
250.
what if I want the radius I can't do
that but I have to go
and I have to press this corner R so
that means this is what I want
and I'm gonna input 250 000 again I'm
gonna press this one now it's gonna let
me show you r250 that is going to round
it up to 250 000. or do we want 250 000
corner and then let's say what do we
want to do let's call it down to one
one inch and 990 and let's say how far
we want to go we want to go three inches
right so that would be like a very basic
line
there's another way to but sometimes
what happens
let's say for example you know you have
a part it did the corner and but these
edges sometimes are a little bit sharp
there's a way to actually go and round
the rock you can throw varices
into these corners
but you have to change the program a
little bit instead of a line
we're gonna do a taper because taper
you're telling machine don't go you're
telling the machine not to go straight
but we're gonna taper it and the taper
you can control the angle as well you
can control it by uh you know 45 30
degrees whatever you want this is where
the taper is necessary so
if you want to make it simple 250
Corners perfect
uh if you have a 30 degree for example
chamfer this is not going to work you
you'll have to create a taper and
actually you know and paper is also very
nice because it will calculate some
dimensions for you and I'm gonna show
you that in a second so I'm gonna go do
paper
okay
so instead of line now we have a taper
and what I'm gonna do I'm gonna press
this one
and I'm going to do a 10 000 radius as a
starting point
final point x let's say so this is two
inches
from here to here we know this is two we
want 250 000 corner right so from here
okay that'll be 250 but remember the
tool always goes to the bottom so the N
actually diameter it's 250 times two
because it's 250 here
and 250 here so
the starting point
of this will be actually one and a half
inches
but from here to here it's going to be
250 000.
so like I said the reason why it's
always double because when we cut
remember we only cut up to the center we
never go past the center right because
the part is spinning
so final point x
1.5
okay where are we starting starting
point on the Z we're starting from the
from the beginning
let's change this morning so and just to
make it even number
uh okay and then where we going so we're
going to two inches and how far we're
going on a z we're going to 250 000. now
we're asking you final corner so this is
a beginning corner and this is the final
Corner well let's break it also
okay so I did ten thousand
I press the radius I'm gonna hit that
enter
okay so now it gives me a 10 000 radius
so okay that's all peachy so this is
actually our radius
so what I would do
I'm gonna press enter
okay right hand Arrow insert
and now we have another line so now I
have a line
and I can do
two inches
and three inches honestly right my part
is done I have a beautiful chamfer with
a nice radius so there's no sharp
corners
but for example what if you're doing uh
let's say you don't know what your ax is
so what you do you go here
and it's gonna show you enter PT okay
so do a question mark
okay
we know it's gonna be a 45 angle let me
bring my calculator here
so we say okay that it's gonna be a 45
angle chamfer Reynold it's gonna be 250
000. okay long we know our finishing
diameter we know we're starting from
point but I don't know where it starts
once you have this question mark and
those three are filled with an angle
okay you go here
one is gonna say calculate okay I'm
gonna press it and you'll see what's
going to happen
and it's going to give you calculation
same thing and this works really nice
for example
you have a 30 degree that it's calling
for so we all know all these points but
we don't know what's going to be the
starting point x you have question mark
right I'm gonna do that right hand soft
key
calculate and boom
now it gives us a different number so
let's say our program is done we want to
make sure everything was good I'm gonna
go to the program
I'm gonna go to the tool path
I'm gonna press part
once I press the part it's going to give
me like a nice
kind of drawing of it
I can go over here
I do scale change
okay I'm gonna lower this I'm gonna
press it over here right now it's
showing my scale is at 1.71
so let's go point eight
enter
okay I have to hit part again and now I
have a bigger
now I have a little bit bigger part so
as you see over here let's say
we want to focus on the Champ for a
little bit more
I'm gonna go point
three
okay
this is our chamfer and let's say you
want to have a bigger radius or you make
some changes whatever it is right you go
to program
program added for example
uh you know
the radiuses are a little bit too small
radius this could be much bigger
thirty thousand same thing is I'm Gonna
Change it to 30 pounds 60 000 on that
mistake 400 30 000 it's enough
for
that sometimes
a program
that
art
and what happened so the drawing or the
trace that I had before disappeared if
you wanna if you make changes and you
want this to remember you go here
and you do store once you do store
Whatever You're Gonna Change and you're
gonna bring bring it you're gonna come
back to the trace or two path uh it's
gonna remain like exactly where you left
before right and
I'm here to 0.3 heart
and now you see the radiuses are much
nicer
so this is a pretty much our basic kind
of like how you do it and now there you
have a program you can go to single
block
these are our units so we have a facing
right and I'll be turning but you can
just press the memory and I'm sure
there's not participant highlighted Let
It Go and pretty much and you're gonna
start making chips
now let's see scale change let's go to
three inches
if you wanna see what your tool does
okay just go over here on the left side
continue
Let's Help task continue we'll show you
all the approaches all the cuts how far
it's gonna go and all these things if it
does it too fast
you can do half and step and it will
take you step by step by step by step
like every single move and you can
follow these numbers the position
numbers and it's going to show you
exactly what it's doing if let's say for
example you don't see the actual
position number you see the machine
number
press the right key and just highlight
this and this is what shows it says
coordinates if I press it and I turn
green it shows
the part
all right guys uh thank you for watching
and until next time